how's it going bros my name is Pam and
welcome to fine when paired back it's
still only doing one hand
breaking microphone last week I said I
had some special news for you bros that
could change the world
yeah I'll say like that I've been
nominated to go home
king of the web basically how the
website works is that you should check
the link in the description you can vote
10 times a day and the winner gets seven
thousand five hundred u.s. American
dollars that's a lot of money I never
had that much money in my entire life
probably I'll never work I didn't really
want to run for King on the web first I
really think it's a weird way for like
asking your fans for money so I wasn't
actually going to do it but being
inspired by my girlfriend my close
friend Jonas and other youtubers I
decided to run it for charity so I'm
actually gonna win that the wrong I'm
actually I've caught it I'm gonna win
I'm actually gonna donate all the prize
money that I get to share it to an
organization that I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with WWF they help Adam
animals around the world so yeah I
really hope you take part of this I
would really much appreciate it all you
have to do is like I said check the link
in description I feel like there's
there's no reason for anyone who
bothered listened to me talk about this
for so long not to actually go and take
those extra seconds to both others
things that you can do to support is
like this video favorite it and share it
with someone who you think might enjoy
this cause I'm actually also gonna do a
livestream on Sunday this Sunday GMT
plus one time I leave a link in the
description for what time it is if you
are in a different time zone I'm
actually gonna do that for charity as
well I'm gonna play amnesia and since I
my twitch partner now I decided that all
the money that I make from that setting
I'm gonna get dead
donate towards WWF I really hope with
the help of the bro army and maybe even
other youtubers we could do this and
support charity do the right thing I am
pretty pie for the inspirational music
alright so that was pretty much it Rosen
joined this Friday I'm sorry it was kind
of different from usually it's not like
me making funny faces you're helping out
there's my plane as always I'm gonna end
it with the brofist hope you actually
gonna brofist
I saw you saw you last time you didn't
bro fish I'm disappointed I do just sat
down but I i'm so tired i would do it
when I'm dead I don't care if you die do
it alright